the left-hander john means that's what
he's done this year
eight starts 4-0 with a 1.2 era
more strikeouts in innings pitch for the
first time in his career to this point
opponents batting averaged just
152 off of john means
center field mullins back gliding
and catching on the run just before the
warning track
raised down in order tampa bay rays it
will be
left hander ryan yarbrough getting the
traditional start and this is the
breakout the career splits
on yarbrough as a starter and as a
reliever the record
huge difference you get a pretty
substantial difference in era
trey mancini steps in
that's hammered way back out of here
trey mancini all over that one
and the orioles take a one-nothing lead
man he gave it a ride
boom boom how about that one first ball
looking and
he got that cut fastball we've been
talking about but it was a mistake
left right in the middle part of the
plate and trey mancini
here's the grip there's the spin and i
promise you he gets
every stitch of this one out towards
left center field this is a bomb
and here we go freddie galvez steps in
ready with
99 career home runs
and maybe there's a hundred way back in
left field that one
is gone career number 100
for freddie galvez way to go freddy
you don't have to be 6-3 230 to hit the
long ball ben
all you needs a little bat speed and the
square it up and you talking about round
ball round bat but he squares this one
up big time this freddie galvez
98 off the bat 381 feet his fifth
long ball of the season mount castle at
third top of the order
mullins he's after the first pitch gonna
be a play at the plate
the runner is out there mount castle
trying to score from
third on that little tap and the rays
cut him down
for the second out i'll tell you that
that is the norm now
you know the the contact play you're
going
and right here this ball hit right at
lau
set your feet make the throw plenty of
time
get you out of the plate and you know
you're right about that
you see that more and more if that guy
is at third
he's coming down the line his bases are
loaded for trey mancini
now mancini base has loaded two down 2-1
to mancini
hit hard down the left-field line that's
a fair ball
two runs are in hayes streaking around
third
they're going to send him he is in at
the plate
trey mancini three more rbis
five nothing orioles
well half a day trey mancini huh
solo home run in the first inning base
is loaded this is a rocket chain jump
didn't get it where he wanted trying to
go down in the way and trey mancini
all over this one right down the left
field line you knew two runs were going
to score the only question is
could austin hayes score all the way
from first base cenino leads major
league baseball and at bats for homer
homer's every 8.7 at bats that's ahead
of
buxton tatis akuna and judge and down he
goes strike three
john means first strike out of the game
that means he's been sharp so far
they're more than a hundred over that
and there's strike three speak of the
devil
means throws one by brasso two down well
he slowed the bat down twice
change up and that big sweeping breaking
ball then he takes that old four-seam
fastball at 94 and just kind of
up and away rides it right by payoff
pitch
swing and a miss goes down to a knee
it's a fast ball down low
three punch outs for john means in the
top of the third
he keeps the orioles five nothing
so two god here's brasso
he pitches swinging a fly ball into left
field
with hayes turning and looking at the
wall in brussels with a two-round homer
he is homered for the fourth time in his
career against john means
and the rays are on the board down five
to two
touched on it during the last at-bat
that mikey brasso
could be a key to the raise getting
going again against left-handed pitchers
and just dunked one in the first couple
of rows out there in left field for his
fourth home run of the season
got a change that uh stayed up you
breathe new life into that dugout now
you're down just three runs
offense another home run see there's a
hot
shot back into deep left that ball is
going to carry out of here
and the rays have gone back to back
rosarina's
fifth home run of the year so the rays
put up three in a hurry here in the
fifth
now the rays trail by only two
another fastball in that was missed he
has been missing in
off the plate in off the plate all night
long heart of the order will bat against
ryan yarbrough and that means trey
mancini
what a night he's had
center field and deep back it is
out of here trey mancini is going crazy
tonight
two homers
rbis every time you look at him he's
driven in
five well how about you trey mancini huh
nine home runs now that's his fifth rbi
of the game so two home runs
a double and this one straight
away center field high fives in the
oriole dugout and that's how you get
one of those runs back
you're swinging a high towering drive at
a deep left all the way back to the wall
of rose arena jumps up makes the catch
up off the top of the wall randy
rosarina took a home run away
and there are two out in the sixth
and he went up to the very top of the
fence and that's why they built that
fence
so low for plays just like that but the
uh
the thought then was to have the orioles
tape home runs away but this one
is taken away from the oreos did a
two-run home run in the eighth inning
last night
and he lines it into center for a base
head
keermeyer is going to head to the plate
and the rays make it a two-run ball game
so choy comes through coming off the
bench and a solid rbi
single into center 6-4 now
here is randy rosarina and he
shoots one deep to left and that baby's
going to get out of here
a long shot by rosarina his second home
run of the night
and just like that the rays have tied
this game
three pitches from plutco and the rays
have even the score at six
that's not a good ratio three pitches
three runs joy knocked in a run with a
single
and he takes it into center and serves a
base hit
here comes the damage and the rays are
going to take the lead
how about that joy
comes up with a big base hit again
he's been so short to the baseball
this ball bouncing away and the reigns
are going to get another run
kermeyer comes down from third and the
rays now have an
8-6 lead 5-0
all o's in complete control
and it's been all raised ever since
rosarina homer in the seventh
the 2-2 and he lines this one back into
left that ball is going to be off the
wall
hayes will play the carom choi's going
to score and into second base goes to
rhodes arena
and boy what a night it has been for
randy rosarina
two home runs now a double
four runs batted in on the night and the
rays
make the eighth inning a three-run
inning the rays have come back from a
five-nothing deficit
carrying a 9-6 lead into the bottom of
the ninth inning
and they put it in the hands of pete
fairbanks
really get a second 3-2 breaking ball
here it comes
base hit right center field
stewart scores mancini in at third
and the lead is cut to two it's a nine
seven game
pedro severino's got an rbi that last
strike
that last out to get here it is
and a chopper deep from short the throne
is second going to be
in time and what a play to end this game
adamus got back toward the hole
and made that quick move to
second base but they went at 9-7